est-ce que comme tous les mecs de 49 ans
vous prenez du viagra sans le dire
ça va bien
style gangs
alors donc plus de 10 ans après la
sortie de cyberpunk le dernier album
donc de Billy Idol et ben il revient il
revient avec un nouvel album qui
s'appelle Devil's playground c'est à
dire le terrain de jeu du diable Jean tu
avais noté dans le premier signal est
Scream en 1994 Billy Idol suite à
l'échec de cyberpunk vous avez été
hospitalisé à Los Angeles
pour une overdose
alors vous aviez des enfants encore
encore jeune à l'époque et un ami vous
dit il aurait passé le reste de leur
existence à se dire que tu te souciais
pas à ces deux pour rester en vie
et
ils auraient pas eu le temps
je suis ici aujourd'hui à faire du rock
à l'époque vous étiez complètement dans
ce que vous appelez le zoom bilan quoi
c'était
des gens comme moi avant
de parler de ce genre de choses
sérieusement
je vous ai mis 10 ans quand même
c'était des enfants qui comptaient plus
pour moi que moi-même donc je revenais
vers ceux qui comptaient le plus mon
grand amour le premier amour c'est la
musique c'est vrai être sur scène mais
mes amis mes enfants sont complètement
puissants
vous avez fait des cures de
désintoxication vous avez vous avez fait
quoi
de désintoxication je me suis sevré
progressivement il faut dire que j'avais
une raison d'être de vivre qui dépassait
tout que
c'était
ce qui comptait le plus mes enfants donc
je voulais pas disparaître je voulais
pas être
ivrogne avec mes gamins je voulais pas
être raté avec mes enfants il faut il
faut être cool il fallait être en
contact avec mes enfants disons et donc
je me suis dit que c'était ce qu'il y
avait de mieux à faire et il m'avait
jamais rien vu boire et je crois que
c'était ça qu'il fallait faire être
correct avec eux je pouvais boire dans
mon coin sans qu'il me voit avec qui
dira par exemple aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
vous avez vous avez quoi vous avez 50
ans aujourd'hui
donc 49 quand même on va faire une
interview 59
[Musique]
Billy
Idol est-ce que comme tous les gens de
49 ans vous essayez de draguer des
jeunes en boîte
une copine qu'on peut appeler le soir
quand on veut qui débarque à poil sous
un manteau c'est très bien comme ça
on a plus les moyens
[Rires]
est-ce que comme tous les mecs de 49 ans
vous prenez du viagra sans le dire
diagra et compagnie bien sûr je reprends
avec plaisir ainsi il faut faire ce
qu'il faut faire avec votre nana faut
faire ce qu'il faut mais je crois que ce
qu'elle préfère c'est la langue donc pas
besoin de Viagra pour ça Jean-Marie
et de xanax tu bandes pas mais tu t'en
branles
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que comme tous les mecs de 49 ans
vous croyez toujours que vous avez 20
ans
bien sûr bien sûr est-ce que comme tous
les mecs de 49 ans vous rentrez le
ventre quand vous marchez sur la plage
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est-ce que comme tous les mecs de 49 ans
vous avez peur de mourir
une tournée des concerts
c'est pour ça qu'on a envie de vivre au
contraire est-ce que comme tous les mecs
de 49 ans vous trouvez que vous êtes
encore pas mal pour votre âge
pour changer mon visage mais enfin le
reste le corps on peut travailler dessus
et ça reste en forme comme vous voyez
ça va plutôt bien
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu